you
[Music]
your wake up in the morning with a smile
on your face because you already know
it's going to be a good day the sun is
shining and it's really nice breeze on
your skin and you have the whole day
ahead of you and you can pretty much do
whatever you want but the first thing
you do is you gotta water your plan
that's how you feel when you wake up in
stardew valley you have a lot of stuff
to get done there's so much you haven't
accomplished you got this small farm and
it needs a lot of love there's rocks at
trees and grass over growing the whole
area you got to clean it all up there's
a cave with slimes and bats
you got to mine it to the bottom and get
all those minerals there's ponds and
streams an entire ocean to fish there's
a town of people that don't know you
very well and because they don't know
you they don't like you so you got to
make this effort to get to know them I
mean they really don't like you I went
to this dance and no one would dance
with me no one not even you come on I
mean it can kind of feel overwhelming
but if you take it day-by-day and you
just focus on one task at a time it's
pretty amazing how much you can
accomplish start out with a pretty
simple watering can and it takes some
time to water all your crops but once
you get into the swing of things you can
get all your farming work done by about
10:00 a.m. that gives you the rest of
the day to explore the town and do
whatever
there are a lot of options in stardew
valley you can take on tasks from people
in the town there's a town store you can
go to to get new seeds and try out
different types of farming people will
ask for things like fish or a type of
fruit or vegetable you got to collect it
a certain amount of time and deliver it
you can investigate the forest and
forage for items you spend a lot of your
time just walking exploring land
figuring out what you want to do I spent
most of my time in the caves at first
it's pretty rough there's a lot of
little things in the mines that can come
after you and using the pickaxe on the
rocks takes a lot of your energy but if
you can make it down five levels it
opens up an elevator that way the next
time you visit the mines you can take an
elevator to a lower floor as long as you
go down five levels you're slowly
getting better further and further down
the mine you get better loot and you
start getting equipment like boots and
swords and the further you go you can
find really high-end stuff like diamonds
and items that you don't even know what
they are you could take them to a
blacksmith to get them opened up or to a
museum so you can learn more about them
every day I was in the mines I was
progressing but you progressed in every
way and start you tally even when you're
focusing on one thing like getting to
the bottom of that mine as you sell your
harvests and the things that you find
you make enough money to buy things like
a little barn and get some chickens and
then you get to pet them and you get
their eggs a little bit more time and
you get to buy a bigger barn and then
you get some cows and then goats and
maybe a sheep you can turn the milk into
cheese and the eggs into mayonnaise and
the sheep's wool into cloth you can
harvest the crops into jelly and pickles
and oil and beer you get a big farm with
sprinklers that water your crops for you
so you can spend even more time doing
whatever it is that you want to do you
build a life for yourself
and that's my favorite part about
stardew valley there's really no wrong
way to spend your time whether you make
a massive garden or pursue the talents
people or chip away at the mines
wherever you spend your time is good
because you're always progressing no
matter how many days I spent in those
mines I was always taking care of my
farm in the morning I increased my
skills and my items and I kept moving
it's been over a year in the game since
I started I have a big farm a nice house
and a kitchen and I finally made it to
the bottom of that mine now that spring
dance is coming around again and I'm
thinking I might be interested in trying
to get someone to dance with me and
that's what makes stardew valley so
sweet you'll feel rewarded every day for
living the way you want to live so you
can clear out the pathway to investigate
more of the woods or explore the weird
sewer tunnel find out what makes the
howling noises when it rains play an
arcade game at the bar or go on a date
it's up to you day is yours to do with
whatever you want so spend it the way
you want to do it as Joe Dirt would say
life's a garden dig it
[Music]
you
[Music]